Transcriptor: Javier Ignacio Moyano
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
En una noche de invierno,
en un auto de alta gama.
Al costado de una villa de Mataderos
en la Ciudad de Buenos Aires.
Vidrios empañados,
gemidos y algunos gritos
se escuchaban desde adentro.
Patrulleros, narcos,
merodeando por alrededor.
Ahí estaba una mujer desnuda,
arrodillada en el asiento trasero.
De frente a una tarta de jamón y queso
recién horneada apoyada
sobre la luneta trasera.
Viviendo un eterno parto multi-orgásmico.
Todo eso pasó en mi auto.
Ni les cuento lo que fue
llevarlo al lavadero.
Esta experiencia surreal pero verídica
fue todo lo opuesto al primer parto
que presencié en mi vida.
Era mi primer día de guardia en el
hospital siendo estudiante de partera.
Y tenía tanta emoción e ilusión,
imagínense, iniciaba mis prácticas,
iba a ser una parte de la vida
de las personas.
Y lo que viví en ese momento
fue impactante.
Creí que la mujer iba a morir desangrada.
Sentí miedo.
Pero por cómo se veían los demás
se trataba de un típico parto estándar,
normal, sin complicaciones.
La mujer estaba acostada boca
arriba sobre una camilla.
Tenía las piernas atadas colgando
de unas tiras de cuero.
Le habían puesto en el brazo
un goteo endovenoso con medicación
para acelerar el parto.
Sobre su cuerpo había un persona
apretándole el vientre
como si ella fuera un pomo de dentífrico.
Le cortaron la vagina.
Era el primer parto que veía.
Veía que salía bastante sangre.
Mientras la mujer hacía fuerza,
le separaban los genitales
como si el dentista quisiera abrirte
la boca al tamaño de un pomelo.
Cuando la cabeza del bebé asomó,
quien asistía el parto lo tomó,
lo tironeó hasta que salió por completo.
Se lo veía azul y flácido
colgando de las manos de otra persona
que lo envolvió en unas telas.
Se lo acercó a la madre
para que lo viera un momento
y rápidamente se lo llevó
para dejarlo en observación.
Mientras la madre quedaba sola
en un pasillo agotada,
mirando el techo con los brazos vacíos
entre perdida y desinteresada.
El resto continuó con su actividad
como si nada hubiera pasado.
Yo que esperaba ese primer parto
con tanta ansiedad y tanto anhelo,
quedé sintiéndome vacía y desorientada.
Así fueron pasando los años
entre cientos de nacimientos,
que llegaron a ser miles
y miles, sin exagerarles.
En los que me surgían siempre
las mismas preguntas.
¿Era necesario usar medicación
para acelerar el parto?
¿Era correcto apretarle los vientres
a las mujeres y cortar su genitales?
¿Hubiera sido más fácil el parto
con la mujer sentada o agachada?
Buscando estas respuestas llegué a Canadá
donde pasé unas semanas
junto a colegas parteras.
Viendo que las mujeres que parían con
con ellas tenían la libertad de probar
y cambiar posiciones constantemente.
De sentarse, agacharse, caminar,
estar acompañadas siempre por alguien
de sus afectos.
Abrazar y acariciar a sus parejas
sin ningún tipo de censura.
Darse baños de inmersión
lo que les permitía transitar y atravesar
mucho mejor el dolor del parto.
Algunas incluso se ponían
en posición de cuatro patas,
que era un poco raro.
Pero entendí que seguimos siendo
hembras mamíferas aunque
pidamos delivery o usemos el WhatsApp.
Este fue el primer contacto que yo tuve,
a pelo, con partos desinhibidos.
Y estando lejos de casa,
les voy a confesar algo,
probé las drogas del parto natural,
que me llevaron
a una irresistible adicción sin retorno.
Especialmente, a la oxitocina.
Una poderosa sustancia que fabricamos
en nuestro cerebro y viaja por la sangre.
Presente en altísimas concentraciones
cuando nos abrazamos, nos acariciamos,
cuando compartimos momentos
muy placenteros con otros
como jugar un picadito
de futbol con amigos.
Cuando reímos a carcajadas limpias
estando solos o acompañados.
Cuando nos damos besos apasionados.
Cuando parimos a un bebé naturalmente.
Cuando nacemos,
cuando amamantamos un bebé
y, especialmente, cuando
nos echamos un buen polvo.
(Risas)
Pero las bondades de la oxitocina
exceden la sexualidad humana
y al mundo de la maternidad.
La oxitocina previene
la hipertensión arterial,
evita accidente cardiovasculares,
previene enfermedades crónicas
degenerativas y el cáncer.
Y, sobre todas las cosas,
nos empuja a sentir estados emocionales
de plenitud y de calma.
Que nos dan la confianza para entablar
vínculos afectivos libres de violencia.
Cómo la naturaleza tiene todo
tan fríamente calculado,
la oxitocina dispara la fabricación
de otras poderosas drogas:
Las beta endorfinas.
Las beta endorfinas son potentes
calmantes y sedantes similares al opio.
Para contrarrestar el tan temido fantasma
del dolor insoportable del parto.
Las beta endorfinas recompensan
el cansancio físico y el gran esfuerzo
con estados de mayor energía,
de bienestar y de alegría.
Que es lo que sentimos cuando
hacemos deporte y actividad física.
Ganándose el título de las hormonas
de la felicidad, el placer
y la trascendencia, la superación.
En lo personal, la fisiología del parto
y del nacimiento me maravillan
porque tenemos todo
ese potencial biológico
en nuestros cuerpos.
Estas sustancias se encadenan
con otra hormona, la prolactina,
Que durante el trabajo de parto termina
de madurar los pulmones del bebé,
para que cuando nazca
respire sin dificultad.
Pero no solo eso,
la prolactina induce en la madre
un estado de ternura hacia el bebé
y de tigreza hacia el entorno.
Cuidado con acercarse
a una hembra mamífera.
La prolactina permite el cuidado
y la supervivencia de las crías.
Pero también protege a los niños
de la violencia familiar
Porque nos pone un freno
cuando ya estamos cansados de los chicos
y queremos ahorcarlos.
Sobre el final del parto,
entra en escena una última
hormona muy conocida:
La adrenalina.
La adrenalina te coloca
"pum para arriba",
te endereza, te dilata las pupilas,
te despeja, te pone alerta.
Protege el corazón y el cerebro del bebé
en su pasaje por el canal de parto.
Inyecta en la mujer una fuerza descomunal
para que luche y se enfrente
a la ardua tarea de parir.
Este momento es sublime.
Las mujeres cobran una belleza
y poder extraordinario.
Que algunos, sobre todos a quienes
están desacostumbrados puede
generarles bastante miedo.
Recuerdo un varón
que me miraba con los ojos desorbitados
abiertos como el dos de oro,
viendo la expresión de su mujer pariendo
aterrorizado.
Me miraba y pensaba
que ella iba a pegarle.
(Risas)
Yo me reía un poquito por dentro.
Me generó entre gracia y ternura.
Estas hormonas se generan
en altísimas concentraciones.
Hormonas del amor, de la felicidad,
de la ternura, de la superación,
de la euforia, de la fuerza.
En tan altas concentraciones que desbordan
el cuerpo de la mujer y del bebé.
Y como un perro mojado que se sacude
impregna a todas las personas que
están de cerca compartiendo ese momento.
Para que se activen y se fabriquen
estas sustancias
-- del amor, de la ternura,
de los gemidos, de los orgasmos,
del destape, de la "cachondez" --
son necesarios entornos
de privacidad y de intimidad,
donde la mujer se sienta, y todos,
respetada, segura, cuidada, en confianza.
Esto es posible en un lugar más parecido
a un "telo" que a un quirófano.
Pero más allá de esta explicación
entretenida, científica, lógica,
seguramente haya algunas de Uds.
que crean profundamente que
el parto es un evento riesgoso.
De hecho, el promedio nacional de cesáreas
así se los confirmaría.
Según registros recientes de la
Organización Mundial de la Salud
casi siete de cada diez mujeres
son operadas en el sistema médico
privado en nuestro país.
Terrible.
Nos hacen creer que la naturaleza
está fallada en nosotros
y necesitamos de la
asistencia médica en los partos.
Sin embargo, la Organización
Mundial de la Salud
recomienda una tasa de cesárea de entre
el 10% y el 15%. [Fuentes: OMS | OPS]
Y afirma que cuando
la tasa de cesáreas supera ese 10 %,
aumenta la mortalidad de mujeres y bebés.
Esta discordancia
nos da un poco que pensar.
Entonces,
¿qué es lo que causa esta epidemia
reconocida en nuestro país
de cesáreas?
Uno de los motivos
es el uso indiscriminado
de goteos endovenosos
con oxitocina artificial.
Si bien copia algunos efectos
de la oxitocina natural,
carece de la inteligencia para proteger
a la mujer y al bebé durante el proceso.
¿Por qué?
Porque impide que se active el cóctel
de las otras hormonas,
que son protectoras durante
el proceso del parto y del nacimiento.
Hace algunas décadas se llevaron
a cabo varios estudios que mostraron
que el uso excesivo de procedimientos
y de rutinas médicas en los partos
agrede, afecta hostil
y violentamente el desarrollo natural,
se asocia a mayores índices
de delincuencia, de drogodependencia,
suicidios,
trastornos del espectro autista
y violencia en la sociedad.
Lo cual nos toca a todos,
directa o indirectamente.
Además de poner en riesgo la vida
de madres, mujeres, bebés
o incluso provocarles la muerte
o dejarles secuelas y discapacidades
para el resto de su vida.
Tiempo atrás me contactó
una mujer embarazada.
Ella tenía dos hijos nacidos por cesárea.
El menor de ellos
había desarrollado autismo.
Investigando acerca de esta condición
ella supo que se trataba de una
predisposición genética.
Que, según algunos estudios, resulta
en bajos niveles de oxitocina en sangre.
Y que la forma de nacer
para estas personas
podría ser un factor clave,
además de otras múltiples causas
para activar o silenciar estos genes.
Y que un parto que permite y estimula
la fabricación espontánea de oxitocina
en altas concentraciones en la madre
y en el bebé,
y además protege y permite después
del nacimiento un contacto inmediato
madre-hijo, piel con piel,
por un tiempo prologando,
favorecería un desarrollo
neurológico normal
y podría anular
una de las potenciales causas.
Contar con esta información fue lo que
a ella la determinó para elegir
un parto vaginal después de dos cesáreas
sin intervenciones para el nacimiento
de su tercer hijo.
Otro ejemplo es el uso
de narcóticos artificiales
también derivados del opio,
similares a las beta endorfinas,
como la meperidina o la nubaina,
que facilita y predispone a las personas
el desarrollo a la drogodependencia.
Estos químicos artificiales o naturales
dejan huellas.
Vos, Uds., todos nosotros,
¿qué sistema químico elegimos activar
y alimentar desde el inicio de la vida?
¿Al sistema del miedo, del dolor,
de la violencia?
¿De la desconfianza, de la atención?
¿O al sistema del amor,
de la cachondez, del abrazo,
del éxtasis, de la calma, de la felicidad?
La manera de nacer importa
porque la química del parto
nos va a acompañar siempre.
Michel Odent, un médico francés
partero y anestesista,
autor de muchísimos libros traducidos
a decenas de idiomas,
que ha escrito sobre el cóctel
de las hormonas del amor,
las funciones de los orgasmos,
la importancia de las parteras,
el daño de los plásticos y las drogas
usadas en los partos
y el impacto en la sociedad
-- y a quien les recomiendo que lean --
nos dice que para cambiar el mundo,
primero hay que cambiar
la forma de nacer.
Tal vez, pienses que nada
podes hacer con esta información.
Pero sí podes cambiar
la forma de nacer de alguien.
Y eso va a repercutir en su vida
y en todos nosotros como sociedad.
Parir y nacer naturalmente
valen la pena y el esfuerzo.
Y las intervenciones e interferencias
médicas deberían estar justificadas.
La forma de nacer en el presente
será la plataforma para nuestro futuro.
(Aplausos)